joining me now tulsi gabbard former
hawaii congresswoman
and former presidential candidate
congresswoman great to see you tonight
now january 6th was obviously a sad and
horrific day but my fear in all of this
is that this talk of
this forever threat the enemy within
is just going to mean the government has
more power
and we have fewer rights and freedoms
your thoughts
uh it is an incredibly dangerous
situation we are in with our country on
edge
and this kind of of broad inflammatory
rhetoric
is like throwing a match into the
tinderbox
now what what speaker pelosi is talking
about here
is potentially a very serious thing if
there is evidence
to back what she is saying and her quote
was we have members of congress
who want to bring guns on the floor and
have threatened violence
on other members of congress end of
quote
now we're a country of laws so if what
she is saying is true and there is
evidence to back it up
then this is a legal issue for law
enforcement
when i was a member of congress a few
years ago there was someone in the
public who was making threats on my life
repeatedly saying that he would track me
down
and behead me i reported it to law
enforcement
they investigated the threats found them
to be credible tracked the guy
down charged him prosecuted him he was
found guilty and held accountable for
that crime what nancy pelosi is talking
about here
is a serious crime of terroristic
threatening and
if true should be reported to law
enforcement because members of congress
are not above the law
either however if there is
yeah congressman my point is also
inciting potentially inciting
i mean if you think there's someone
among the republican caucus
who's actively plotting the murder of
nancy pelosi other members of congress
that could then bring violence
upon those individuals some of them we
named in the angle
so that in and of itself is inflammatory
and
perhaps inciting exactly that that's
really the issue here
if if this is a criminal threat let law
enforcement deal with it
if there is no evidence of what she is
talking about and if it's not
true then it is exactly that it is
inciting
further division uh further uh harm
potentially and
further destroying the possibility of of
our country coming together and
this is why it's so important for nancy
pelosi again if if
these these accusations are baseless she
needs to apologize
not really so much to to her colleagues
but really to the american people who
right now
more than ever need leadership coming
from the speaker of the house who
represents all members of congress and
the american people
to bring us together for her and
president biden to de-escalate these
tensions to turn down the temperature
to denounce those who are seeking to
undermine our civil liberties and our
constitutional rights and who are
inflaming
these tensions to say hey we are all
americans
we're all americans and we need to come
together well that's um that would
certainly be a nice thought but
it certainly looks like this is stage
setting going on
congresswoman i mean they're setting the
stage for okay
because of this threat we need to either
have aggressive gun control we need to
put a wall around the capitol
uh we need to have more metal detectors
in washington washington has to be a
state i mean whatever it is
it seems like this is a perfect way for
them to
you know set that narrative and set it
early to justify future encroachment on
civil liberties
and even even if that's what i'm worried
about
yeah i share your same concern because
if if that is the motivation
behind this then it is not a stretch of
the
imagination by any means to say that
well if the party in charge
can extend this kind of government
overreach and using the military and
intelligence agencies against people who
are of the opposing party or who hold
different views
then what's to say the next party who
comes in and takes charge can't do the
same and that
that really leaves us with a banana
republic not a democracy
and that's that's the dangerous path
that we see before us yeah this cynicism
is even infecting uh some republican
lawmakers too take a look
tell me what it's like being in a
capital building
uh surrounded by fencing a war zone not
not the battle part of the war zone but
like a green zone type area
we're supposed to be inviting it's
supposed to be the people's house and to
have it be walled off because we can't
trust that frankly the people won't try
to overrun it
congresswoman what happens when
government officials representatives
stop
trusting their own constituents maybe
they need to go into a different line of
work
yeah it's remembering who all of us who
have served or who serve in elected
positions were there to serve the people
to represent them represent their voices
not be in a position where our
government is now viewing
the people the public as
who the opponent people who may come and
attack them as the threat this is
such an incredibly dangerous thing and
again it just undermines the foundation
that our country was built upon and why
i continue to call for
leadership we need voices of strong
leadership not for one party or the
other right now but
for america america yeah for america
congresswoman wonderful to see you
thanks for joining us tonight